ST
MCDONAGH WHO PUT IT ON NET.
LIGHTNING
NINE SECONDS INTO THE POWER
PLAY.
.
AND BEATS IGOR WAITED FOR A LANE
TO OPEN. IT ON NET.
STOPPED BY VASILEVSKIY AND
ANDREI VASILEVSKIY'S LEFT PAD.
YOU SEE HIM SQUEEZE
CHYTIL PUT IT ON NET.
SMOTHERED BY WITH TWO GOOD SHOT.
THE FIRST ONE BY KAAPO MISSED
ONE!
UP.
SECOND ONE RELEASED.
BEATS VASILEVSKIY ON THE GLOVE
SIDE.
BREAKWAY, THE TOE STOP. AS WELL.
GETS THE LETS ONE RIP INTO THE
BREA
TIME, TOOK A LITTLE OFF, HOPINGR
IN HIS 26 POWER PLAY TAKEAWAY
SHORTHANDED.
WENTETS BACK.
THAT'S ON THE OUTSIDE OF THE
THE BREAK HERE.
RIGHT OFF THE GOAL
ZIBANEJAD AND THE PASS THEYOPEN.
THERE'S NOT MUCH ROOM.
TROUBA CAME TO THE AID OF
MILLER.
KILLORN
SHESTE MOTTE.
IT THE GLOVE OF
VASILE A GOOD SAVEOAL
COMBINED KUCHEROV AND STAMKOS IN
THE FIRST GAME.E. 3-1
RANGERS! 34 GOALS IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
21 CHANCE DENIED BY
THE ICE.IN. DENIED BY VASILEVSKL
SO THEY'RE GOING TO GET A
KEPT IN BY HEDMAN.
KUCHERER THEN THE PUCK
IS GOING TO COME RIGHT BACK TO